hey what's going on is bill burns time
for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday October 1st 2018 what's going on
how are you what are you doing are you
gonna go sober October come on man it
rhymes everybody's doing it I think
Rogan and those guys are doing it again
I would I would do it
but I'm doing Boston this weekend and
there's no [ __ ] way okay this is just
certain cities you can't stay sobering
all right and that's one of them so how
about take it easy
October settle down there [ __ ] October
anyways I just got back from Denver I'll
tell you what a weekend I had by the way
there the [ __ ] cab driver almost
killed me coming home for the [ __ ]
Airport she was a sweetheart right
talking about kids she's a grandmother
and all Alaska well it's got to be
amazing a blah blah she goes to make a
left onto my street and where she turns
her left hand sergeant signal on for
whatever reason she just starts drifting
as she's coasting up to where she's
gonna stop you know to make a left she
starts drifting like over like the white
dotted line there into the right lane so
now people can't go in the left lane and
she's also in the right lane and I'm
literally like moving away from the door
like what the [ __ ]
and people are slowing down beeping at
her so she just cuts the wheels hard
rather than pulling up a little bit and
getting in the lane she cut the wheels
hearts or [ __ ] ass her right ass
cheek of her Prius was sitting in that
[ __ ] Lane and I'm like oh my god
we're gonna get killed so there's all
these cars coming and people are beeping
at her and I could feel her getting
stressed so I just calmly just said yeah
you know there's a lot of traffic that's
this time of day you know there's always
a lot of traffic you know but again just
nice and [ __ ] chill like I'm not
getting impatient right but she's still
gotten patient and she saw a gap and she
shoots through it and I see this [ __ ]
guy on a motorcycle that's a little
ahead of the pack of the cars in the you
know it's two lanes on the other side of
the road he's on the right lane and she
pulls out and I just go guy and I
motorcycle god
I thought the guy was gonna [ __ ]
t-bone write them right into me and she
gets across the street and she laughs at
me she goes I saw him I saw him it's
like you [ __ ] saw him and you still
went I'm telling you that she needed
glasses because every time she would
pull up to a red light she would stop
like 20 car lengths behind and then
slowly like creep up so I don't know
what her [ __ ] deal is she's like I
saw him I saw him yeah I saw - you just
didn't see the [ __ ] look on his face
look like Eli Manning two weeks ago you
know what his face is all mushed up you
got that you know like you saw that
chick in the ring um yeah that's one of
those things where I was just like I
know what that feels like she scared the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of that guy because he
had like a bunch of cars behind him -
and he had [ __ ] slam on that slam but
he had to like that was it was
definitely all right let's be honest you
almost died every time we get on a
motorcycle is pretty much what happened
so I would say on a scale of 1 to 10
that was there was a good 6 it was a 6
but a 6 on a motorcycle is a [ __ ] you
know that's like a 9 in a car it's
probably even worse it's even worse
because like you know he got a airbags
and [ __ ] it's yeah anyways I saw him I
saw him [ __ ] laughing at me like I'm
a [ __ ] little girl in the backseat
I'm like I'm fake you know I don't know
where you're from with that
Transylvanian [ __ ] accent but I don't
know how you do it over there so anyways
what was it Friday night I actually did
a sold-out show at the fabulous forum in
Los Angeles the same place where you
know Larry Bird Magic Johnson had their
great battles with Kevin McHale [ __ ]
clothesline
[ __ ] Kurt Rambis all of that
[ __ ] I saw the great Mario Lemieux play
there I saw Wayne Gretzky play there I
remember seeing the 1999 Lakers there
with like [ __ ] Shaq and Kobe with
Dell Harris coaching and I believe
Dennis Rodman was on that team and then
I you know I saw the Foo Fighters I saw
the Queens of the Stone Age I saw a
bunch of shows there and then all of a
sudden I'm [ __ ] them and I was
unbelievable so I want to thank
everybody who came out to the show not
gonna lie
might have been the best show of my
career I thank [ __ ] christ because I
had a bunch of friends there and that
was not the one where he wanted to walk
offstage like yeah I hit the warning
track and every night that was good it
was an impressive pop-up to make it out
to end the inning bill but we went down
there during the day me and Dean and all
these guys went down there and you know
did the deal you know I set up the drums
and all that we played Dean was posting
clips and [ __ ] Dean has never sung any
better and it was just it was [ __ ] it
was awesome but I almost [ __ ] up
because we played from 2:30 to like 6
o'clock
2:30 to [ __ ] 6 o'clock and like I was
gassed around 5:00 and then another
buddy of ours showed up right at 5:00 so
we played for like another hour and the
foreign people were so cool because they
wanted us done by like 5:30 we just kept
pushing it a little bit and I got off
the stage and I was [ __ ] wiped out
and I was like I'll know that I just
[ __ ] use up all my energy for this
show but fortunately you know the
butterflies get going and everything and
it was so [ __ ] cool they got uh they
got they gave you this little gift bag
I'll tell you this film when you guys
you guys worked there eventually right
one of you guys listening when you
[ __ ] sell it out they got it says
what it's a the forum backstage it was
this really super [ __ ] high quality
like tote bag something that I would
never take
but it had like it was embroidered and
had like the forum logo on it then
inside it had a bunch of t-shirts and
[ __ ] hoodies and stuff that all said
that backstage thing on it so it's kind
of a [ __ ] obnoxious thing to wear if
you have it I guess you'd have to know
you'd be like oh that guy must have
[ __ ] performed at the forum but it
was it was [ __ ] it was so cool so
anyway so I'm waiting to go up and I got
to Dean and [ __ ] Joe bartnik
destroyed and they went up there like
they were going up at like the [ __ ]
the store or the Laugh Factory not an
ounce and Dean's always just [ __ ] got
his arms up like this is gonna be
[ __ ] awesome so he went up there
crushed it comes off stage he's got like
goose bumps and [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
Christmas morning grin on his face and
then Bartnik goes up they're just
[ __ ] levels the place and I don't
know I kind of fed off that I'm like
well these guys aren't even [ __ ]
nervous so I went out there and the
sound is incredible in that place
because now it's it's strictly a music
venue so they fixed all the sound and
you know [ __ ] wasn't bouncing around all
over the place and the crowd yeah you
could bring him up he could bring him
down to a whisper and then get him going
again
and I did like 90 minutes literally
didn't want to get up the stage but I
was so [ __ ] focused on having a good
show because you mean every time I land
at LAX I look at that building and also
the new football stadium they're making
but I always look at the LA forum and I
always just think of the Showtime Lakers
and the Boston Celtics and in the
Pistons when they played him in the find
a stick of all of that like legendary
80s NBA hoop and if I [ __ ] had a bad
set there every time I landed I'd have
to be like oh and I bombed there so I
was on stage about 40 minutes before I
finally stopped and took in the fact
that I was there I was so like you know
focused on just having a good show and I
[ __ ] I'm not gonna lie to you
I got all of that one I walked out of
there no [ __ ] regrets so I really
want to thank everybody I know I've
already said that but I really want to
thank everybody that showed up that was
like the [ __ ] night of my life and
you know I had this great after party
there was all these friends people from
episode family
comedians and people I took acting class
with my wife went out of the way and you
know invited all these friends and
families and it was [ __ ] killer right
and but typical me I'm sitting there I'm
having a good time and all that [ __ ] and
then it's just like I have like a 944
a.m. flight the next day to go to
[ __ ] Denver right to work with
[ __ ] the pride of Trenton New Jersey
Paul virzi right so I kind of learned
something right because I went the next
day I went to Denver and it was this
beautiful Opera House right just [ __ ]
beautiful but it had these really high
high high ceilings in and the balconies
were way in the back and I think that's
so those you know as people sing opera
they're ridiculous so they can just
blast it out and it just fills up the
whole arena like I that's something I
you know when I was in Italy I wanted to
go to one of those and just see what the
big deal was you know see if it made me
cry if I had to bring a handkerchief
that's the funny [ __ ] ever those old
Italian guys go in there [ __ ] crying
so it was designed for that then I came
in there with my [ __ ] dick and [ __ ]
show and I couldn't really hear myself
in the first show and I was kind of
shouting and I had gone on Twitter and I
was reading all these all this [ __ ]
you know the Asteria that's on Twitter
right now with this this Cavanagh and
Ford thing going on and it's it's just
everybody is just yelling at each other
and just everybody's making these
[ __ ] I'm doing it right now saying
everybody but there's a lot of people
are just making these [ __ ] huge huge
huge statements on both sides all of
them just inflammatory for the most part
and
[Music]
I was you know the it's just [ __ ]
it's and so many people were making the
case about themselves under the guise of
supporting the defendant you know and
then there was all these other [ __ ]
idiots on the other side like you know
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] that meathead [ __ ]
and I mean I'm a comedian I got to know
what's going on so I was just sort of
reading that it just sort of affected my
attitude when I went onstage I think I
just came out too [ __ ] hard and
sounded too angry and I had to kind of
adjust on the second show and then I
couldn't really hear myself but we got
it fixed for the next show and then
Sunday night it was great but uh I kind
of learned something where it's like
when you do a show as big as that you
just you don't want to do it again for
like five days you know and then go to a
really [ __ ] small place and kind of
bomb a little bit and just sort of shake
off the memory of what you just did and
then you can just go back to being
normal again because I was like yeah I
was all over the map the first show like
I was still thinking about the forum the
night before going oh wait I did the
joke this because it was you know it was
[ __ ] it was it was incredible
experience the only way I can equated to
it was when I drank at Guinness in
Ireland and I remember drinking it going
this [ __ ] doesn't taste any different
than America and then I came back to
America and I [ __ ] drank at Guinness
and I almost spit it out so then what I
had to do was I had to go [ __ ] drink
like bush light you know and work my way
back up to American Guinness where it
tasted good again you don't mean I think
when you have like a big [ __ ] night
it's probably not a good idea to have a
944 a.m. flight the next [ __ ] day and
then have to go you know I don't know I
don't know I I was like I was kind of
beating myself up going I hope that but
at the end of the end of the show that
they [ __ ] stood up they had a good
time I was like oh that was one of those
ones where I couldn't hear the [ __ ]
laughter so I want to thank everybody in
Denver who came out just [ __ ]
crazy insane great crowds tonight I'm
just me kissing everybody's [ __ ] ass
thank you for you know and Denver is a
place that I've always loved going but I
didn't really get to get out too much
you know cuz I felt like I was gonna get
sick and for once in my [ __ ] life I
actually was like you know what I'm just
gonna stay in the [ __ ] hotel room and
just rest up which is basically what I
did so I didn't even get you know I
always walk around I always go out they
have like these train track things you
know and there's all these like [ __ ]
white kids you see out there it's like
that kid homeless is he playing hacky
like what a hacky sack what the [ __ ] you
know a lot of that [ __ ] weed vibe you
know and they've got all this great
[ __ ] food and I missed all of it but
I did go to Churchill's last night and
had a nice [ __ ] cigar so anyways
sorry man I know this is like a big
[ __ ] Hallmark goddamn podcast but
whatever it's not every day you do the
forum I don't know if I'll ever [ __ ]
get to do that again hopefully I will if
I don't I did it I could have done it
any [ __ ] better through they painted
my name on the [ __ ] wall you know you
look around it says like ac/dc James
Brown all of this [ __ ] [ __ ] there's
my stupid name I mean I'm sure they're
gonna park the forklift in front of it
but whatever for one night for one night
anyways let's talk Formula One racing I
keep forgetting because my [ __ ] DVR
got [ __ ] up I saw I watched the
highlights
Lewis Hamilton one over there I believe
it was in Russia right and it's the
question I have for all you [ __ ] race
fans out there can somebody explain to
me like botas is winning the [ __ ]
race you know and then like you know cuz
Lewis Hamilton you know wants to [ __ ]
he's in second and in Vettel is in third
and amyl tanasul eed but if he if he if
he gets in first then I'll have a 50
point [ __ ] League and Rosberg is his
teammate so the team asked Rosberg to
get out of the way so Lewis will can
pass him and then his job is just
basically then to be a [ __ ]
- basically race against sebastian
vettel to keep the Ferrari team distant
I mean he basically you know for all
extensive purposes he pretty much
wrapped up the [ __ ] thing unless he
crashes or something Vettel comes in
first but even then he would only cut
his lead in half and he like Hamilton
always makes the [ __ ] podium so I get
the whole teammate thing but I remember
when [ __ ] him and Nico Rosberg were
going at it two years ago and the team
asked Luis to [ __ ] move to the side
he's like no I'm good I'm good and I'm
sitting there like going alright is that
because the way he's made up he's a
champion that's what makes him a
champion should botas spend like nah no
I'm [ __ ] good I'm good was Louis in a
position because he's such a star to say
no I'm good to the [ __ ] team and
botas isn't yet but through the guy was
like [ __ ] I mean these guys is what
they do they [ __ ] race it goes
against everything in their [ __ ]
nature to do it any other race Luis was
just like yeah Valtteri he was he was a
gentleman out there today bla bla I
wanted somebody like hey Louis if you
had done that for him I don't think you
would have
anyways max Verstappen got driver of the
day he had like [ __ ] three penalties
he started way in the back and just
within five laps was up to like fifth or
sixth place it was like watching [ __ ]
stroke a race you know when you watch
your movies like nobody can pass people
it doesn't have like that in the race he
started 19th taking the whole [ __ ]
race to get up to the front it's guy in
five laps gave everybody the old right
there Fred so I got my DVR set but that
and I'm back in with the MotoGP and very
excited to be watching that [ __ ] I just
got all this these run run a dates right
up until the Chicago Theatre and then
old Billy boys year is done my [ __ ]
year is done I got a couple of [ __ ]
whatever I got a promote efforts for
family
season 3 whenever we get the date I'm
gonna be doing that towards the end of
year so I will be kind of it never ends
is basically what I'm saying I'll be
flying around [ __ ] promoting the show
but I won't be
like show so my my year ends with the
Chicago theater right after msg Madison
Square Garden then that's it hopefully
I'll be watching the Patriots in [ __ ]
first place and they FC East huge huge
[ __ ] win do you realize if we lost
yesterday we would be three games behind
the Dolphins essentially making plans to
try to get the wild-card that looked
like a like the Patriots team that I've
been spoiled to watch every week we got
a short week though and I'll think
Edelman's back on Thursday so we'll see
we shall see and I was so pulling for
the [ __ ] Cleveland Browns to get two
wins in a row but I like the Raiders too
so it was kind of cool but I just I just
wanted to see you know I don't know I've
already just I've already mentally dealt
with the fact that Brady's not gonna be
here in a couple of years and all these
young kids that I see it coming up we're
gonna be the next ones and so I don't
want to hate on him so I'm just [ __ ]
rooting for him even though I know we're
gonna go right in the [ __ ] Shh the
second Tom Tommy [ __ ] leaves the
goddamn facility oh by the way did I
[ __ ] call the NFC South or did I call
it [ __ ] told you there's no defense in
that entire division look what happened
when they played the [ __ ] bears who
had a defense what the [ __ ] was this
score was like 48 that's [ __ ] seven
let's see here NFL scores what do we got
here what do we got here of course you
got every goddamn score except that one
who do you guys like tonight the Chiefs
of the Broncos I would take the Broncos
and the points because the division
rivalry games are always close and
everyone's gonna be all about they oh my
god the that momma home or whatever the
[ __ ] his name is this guy's a juggernaut
he's due to have a bad game right he's a
rookie
it'll happen Buccaneer I mean the
Buccaneers the [ __ ] Broncos they play
the Chiefs twice a year then they're not
afraid these [ __ ] [ __ ] III would
take them on the points Vaughn will be a
[ __ ] pain in that guy's side that's
what I would do but virzi what Versys
gonna go to the game
and he's gonna bury he's gonna bury the
[ __ ] Chiefs who knows we'll see who's
right
Oh the score was forty eight to ten
pairs and I was also right about the
Yankees after we swept them oh yeah it's
[ __ ] over the red the Yankees are
still a year away Red Sox are looking
like they're gonna win the World Series
look what happens son Chris Sale can't
get [ __ ] healthy price can't beat the
[ __ ] Yankees the Yankees win for the
next [ __ ] six and they're one win
today they win today that I think they
play the Red Sox and there you go it's
like when you watch Friday the 13th
they'd always [ __ ] knock Jason down
and they'd hacked on one [ __ ] time and
then he you got to finish him off it
ain't know til it's over so we shall see
but I'm telling my call is I think the
Indians and the Astros Terry Francona
scares the [ __ ] out of me and when I saw
the Astros win the first two games
against the Red Sox and they had a
chance they came like they were winning
and then we I think we rallied and we
were ahead then all of a sudden right at
the end of the game he had a chance of
sweeping us and went in that last game
they were all up on the top step of the
dugout the whole [ __ ] dugout we're
all standing up they're like let's sweep
their [ __ ] asses and I think I think
I think and they're feeling a little
disrespected out there so we self see if
I said one funny [ __ ] thing this
entire thing I just been like giving out
information
speaking of which more information all
things comedy ATC calm we are we are
releasing our first stand-up special on
our website and it's the great Ted
Alexandro who's really a Comics comic he
just has some he's just I don't he just
has some of the best [ __ ] jokes and
he's one of these guys that is just so
overdue and deserving of a special so
you can watch it but the date what is
the date that [ __ ] putting this thing
on hopefully I got it okay this Thursday
you can what you can stream it at ATC
specials calm now this is huge for for
our website here that you guys
you know watch it and get people here we
can retweet it and get people to watch
the special Ted is [ __ ] hilarious
it's a great special like I said
Thursday a TC specials calm please check
that out all right let me do a little
[ __ ] some advertising reads here
shall we shall we alright all look who's
here old zip you know what's not smart
not smart is written in capital letters
so I yell it whenever it is okay you
know what's not smart job site said
overwhelm you with tons of the wrong
resumes but you know what is smart zip
recruited calm / / unlike other job
sites zip doesn't wait for candidates to
find you zip recruiter finds them it's
powerful matching technology scans
thousands of resumes identifies people
with the right skills education and
experience for your job and actively
invites them to them to apply oh that's
cool it actually goes out eh hey by the
way you're qualified for this we'd love
to have yep she's saying you're invited
so you get qualified candidates fast no
more sorting through the wrong resumes
no more waiting for the right candidates
to apply no more something else they
didn't write anything else but you know
you always need three right it's no
wonder that zip is rated number one by
employees in the US this rating comes
from hiring sites on trust pilot with
over 1000 reviews and right now my
listeners can try zip for free at this
exclusive web address sip recruiter com
/ / that zip recruited com / bar b you
are r zip dot-com / bar tip accrued at
the smartest way to hire all right ah
look who's here hey my [ __ ] bookie hey
my bookie sure watching football is fun
but it's more entertaining when you got
a little action on the games guys you've
heard me talking about this for week
and some of you are still on the
sidelines huh with your junk tucked
between your thighs whether you're an
expert or a rookie you should be betting
at my bookie if you're the kind of guy
that likes to bet a little and win a lot
like playing the numbers on on roulette
you can create a big parlay pick three
teams to win and if you hit all three
you'll turn a hundred dollars into six
hundred dollars it's not just football
you can bet all major sports you can bet
on what time your wife's gonna start
complaining not kidding
take em ma this weekend oh my god you
can bet on this Conor McGregor I can't
wait for this fight steps into the
Octagon Saturday for his first US UFC
fight in two years that was two years
ago Jesus Christ times flying you can
bet on things like whether he'll win
straight up or whether oh god I better
say this guy's name right khabib is that
what it is I will deliver a first round
KO I reckon I recommend hey what's the
over-under that he's gonna say you're
gonna do nothing I love what he says
then you'll do nothing I know what that
is a ringtone I want that on my phone
right next time my wife yells at me I
just want to press that yo dude Alton I
recommend these guys because I really
trust them evidently
this is the one bet I know you'll be
happy with all season my bookie how you
doing it has been in business for years
they've got great online reviews and
their mobile site is easy to use if
you're on the sidelines now is the time
to get the game my bookie the hoof hope
will still match your first deposit
dollar-for-dollar but you gotta join now
because they'll be pulling that offer
log on to my booking my bookie are you
doing I'm just listening right now and
double your money use promo code and
you'll get your I guess it's burrow I'm
guessing I have no idea and you'll get
your first deposit matched 100% that's
promo code parentheses promo code what
the [ __ ] is my promo code how am I going
to get paid you play you when you get
paid
I would just use be URR wasn't it bill
bets I can't remember all right oh look
who's here Dollar Shave Club dude do you
have a [ __ ] shower you're stinky
[ __ ] or brush your teeth or
trying to make your hair look
presentable well here's some good news
oh uh well don't cry wait till you
[ __ ] hear what it is okay
Dollar Shave Club has a lot of stuff to
help you out
that's kind of a [ __ ] levius I'm good
knows exclamation point Dollar Shave
Club has a lot of stuff to help you out
not saying that's not exciting but I
don't think it's exclamation point
exciting Dollar Shave Club yes that
Dollar Shave Club delivers everything
you need to look feel and smell your
best you name it shampoo conditioner
Body Wash toothpaste hair gel condoms we
don't do that even a wipe that'll leave
you a tush feeling tingly clean yes it
does it's like there has a wintergreen
or something on it makes your [ __ ]
feel alive you'll be a big fan of their
amber and lavender calming body cleanser
after you try it the first time I should
walk around with that [ __ ] on me just to
keep my temper in check good luck
finding a product that great at the
store all of Dollar Shave club's
products are made with top-shelf
ingredients that won't break your budget
you'll feel the difference plus shipping
is free with your membership and here's
a great way to try a bunch of Dollar
Shave Club products for just 5 bucks you
can get their daily essentials starter
kit it comes with body cleanser one wipe
Chari
they're amazing butt wipes their
world-famous shave and their best razor
the six blade executive keep the blades
coming for a few bucks more a month add
in some shampoo toothpaste or anything
else you need for the bathroom check it
all out at dollarshaveclub.com / /
that's dollarshaveclub.com / bar all
right Indo cheeto
talk about how the company is expanding
into casual clothing and made-to-measure
measured she knows where Indochina was
also expanding into casual clothing I'm
supposed to talk about that
hey everybody the company's expanding
into casual clothing with
made-to-measure chinos we're Indochina
is also expanding into the cat isn't
that the same thing the company guys I'm
too dumb to [ __ ] talk about your
stuff hey just tell me what this just
write it and I'll read it anyways you're
made-to-measure chinos will quickly come
become your go-to pant pairing as easily
with a suit jacket as they do with this
sweater
what are chinos are those like cool
Dockers let's look those up for a second
let's take a little pause here see what
we got here
chinos pants let's see what they look
like yeah oh yeah oh my god oh I see
what they are
oh they're all snug all snug up on your
nuts and your [ __ ] ass making sure
everything stays high and tight it's
like a facelift for your junk anyways
and they'll be good any time of year for
any occasion from boredom boardroom
meetings to Sunday brunches oh you gotta
love a pair of pants like that right
somebody died to get married I got the
pants and dhoti you know that a Dan in
just an introductory price of $79.90 or
measure at home yourself and shop online
and endo Chino comm choose your fabric
inside and out choose your design
customizations submit your measurements
with your choices relax while your suit
gets professionally tailored and mailed
to you in a couple of weeks this week my
listeners can get any premium premium
indochina suits for $359 and Indo Chino
calm when entering BER at checkout
that's 50% off the regular price for a
made to measure premium suit plus
shipping is free
that's Indo Chino calm promo code bar
for any premium suit for just three
hundred fifty nine dollars and shipping
is free one more people just hang in
there I know it's rough I know you're
having a hard time watching other people
go through a hard time
I really wish I could read you sir
because I started I I've actually I'm
following a couple of people now I
didn't sign up because I know that they
would know that I was following them
sarcastically but you never just have an
account you just have to check in on
check in on I saw one eye I saw I can't
I can't even like this person basically
was a stunning beautiful blonde white
woman and she was talking about how
difficult it was to look the way she
does she compared herself to like a
mermaid like that's what she looked like
so then she did all this other stuff you
know so she wouldn't be so pretty and
get all this [ __ ] attention and I'm
not saying like you know I'm not talking
about creepy guy behavior
I'm just people looking at it or
whatever she's [ __ ] stunning you know
what I mean and it's a sight but look if
you're never gonna wait in a line in
life I mean this is like a price to pay
you know does that make any [ __ ]
sense I mean I get this [ __ ] thing
where it's just like this there's so
many [ __ ] problems in the world right
now it would someone like that and I'm
not talking about me to [ __ ] I'm just
saying this person is just [ __ ] not
even talking about like me to [ __ ] it's
just somehow making all of this meets
who [ __ ] about just as an excuse to talk
about how [ __ ] beautiful she is
basically and how difficult it is you
know it's like you you [ __ ] should
travel a little bit get outside this
country you know go find the people that
actually are making our clothing and see
what their life is and then tell me how
[ __ ] difficult your [ __ ] life is
you know and if we're gonna focus on
anything in this country why don't this
next okay other than cleaning up all the
[ __ ] pollution what about you know
you bite into an apple and there's a
scene if you plant in the ground it
won't [ __ ] grow any more because some
company made sure it wouldn't you know
somebody neutered the [ __ ] goddamn
food it's unbelievable
not a [ __ ] Pete you know not a
[ __ ] peep about it stamps.com
everybody when I walk down the street
it's a beautiful person not having to
stand in line getting free drinks it's
really hard
oh yeah well why don't you [ __ ] put
your arms behind your back put on some
red bottoms shoes and do a faceplant
into the [ __ ] sidewalk okay I'm sure
you won't have any more [ __ ]
difficulty with everybody's jaw dropping
well maybe they'll depend on how bad you
[ __ ] yourself up
stamps.com everybody the US Postal
Service is an important tool for any
business stamps.com is the easiest way
to access all the amazing service
services of the post office Stan's comm
never closes hey guys this should be a
new [ __ ] segment okay
I'll just step on the toes of humble
bragging though I don't want to do that
especially because the guy who created
that unfortunately passed away and I
don't be doing somebody else's bit who
can't even call me out on it all right
but if you guys can just send me like I
just want to read the craziest tweet the
mo from most self-involved to angriest
craziest both liberal and and and
conservative because everybody's just
[ __ ] like freaking out somebody wrote
the me to movement is getting out of
hand
now it only takes 20 accusers to
slightly inconvenience a wealthy man man
with unchecked power that's what I like
how everybody like fudges the numbers
it's like no that's not what happened
that's not what there's been just one
person says something and then somebody
loses their [ __ ] career and then it's
investigated and then a month later
finds out that it was [ __ ] and then
nobody everybody who is trashing the
person nobody issues a [ __ ] apology
to the person and then the person who's
innocent has to then [ __ ] try to
figure out how to get you know they have
to strategize as an innocent person how
to get back into the [ __ ] business
you know but I don't want everything
just to be trashing me too like cuz like
I'll be honest with you okay I usually
don't say way before I like that Ford
woman I believe her
I do you know again this was the big
thing for me was the fact that she's
been telling this stories told to a
therapist she's been she came forward
before against this [ __ ] guy I mean
if this is really just to take this guy
down this has got to be the Melissa
she's like the Terminator of like you
know and he's just him I can't
understand if he's just guilty or like
he's a guy right they're gonna grab the
brass ring and it's gonna be his [ __ ]
shorts are getting yanked down and I
can't tell if he's just [ __ ] wigging
out cuz I haven't watched any of it but
I just read some details so the vibe
really like I'm not gonna sit down and
[ __ ] give myself jury duty why the
[ __ ] would I do that you know a [ __ ]
you know I'll watch the highlights
you know I saw I saw Matt Damon crushing
it doing that my favorite thing was it
came out they said mr. Kavanagh mr.
Kavanagh he just goes anyways yeah he's
just like all over the [ __ ] map and
it reminds me of the Kennedy Nixon
debate and I know that's really a hacky
[ __ ] thing and I'm not saying she's
coming off like Kennedy I'm just saying
he's coming off like Nixon when Nixon
didn't know how to sit he had sweat on
his forehead and that it's like he's a
judge like this guy's not supposed to be
a performer so I don't know it's just
one of those things if the guy's guilty
I hope they say he's guilty and if he's
innocent I hope they say he's [ __ ]
innocence so he doesn't get screwed over
because that's that's what everybody
should want here you know you shouldn't
just want a guy to go free cuz you're a
guy and you shouldn't just want a guy to
get his life burned down because you
know you're a woman you should you know
it's kind of you know it's weird it's
like people are starting to root for
this [ __ ] the way they root for their
sports team where if they have it one of
their players does a piece of [ __ ] move
that's not that bad but then somebody
else - are those guys up there they're
pieces
we're not you know but anyways just so
there's some sort of [ __ ] humor in it
because it really [ __ ] with my
attitude for the first ten minutes of my
set Saturday night and that's not fair
to the people you know they paying to
see a show so some day yeah yeah
yesterday I just started seeing the
humor in it I just started reading him
to virzi and I and I would just I would
go I just go hate Paul like dead serious
and then I would read the tweet like I
was saying it oh wait doesn't Jimmy
Fallon do that do I have one original
[ __ ] idea somebody does that although
you had the somebody has people read
their [ __ ] hate mail alright well now
you know why my act is the level that
it's at because I don't have a [ __ ]
original idea when are they gonna decide
with this [ __ ] guy by the way you
know another [ __ ] - you do an
investigation in a goddamn week trying
to make sure everybody's stories match
up over something from [ __ ] 30 years
ago I don't know man I think you just go
with your gut as far as just if you're
just sitting at home but like the fact
that like what's at stake that that's
what they're gonna base it on I think
like a he [ __ ] seemed crazy she
seemed believable or she seemed coach
and he seems like a passionate family
man you know I guess that no that
doesn't happen when you're going when
you sit on a jury they actually [ __ ]
they have to prove it we're on a sad I
mean it's it's [ __ ] nuts but then
when you get into corporations and [ __ ]
which you saw with Tom Brady it's just
like no we say you suspended your
[ __ ] suspended go [ __ ] yourself or
civil court like that [ __ ] where AJ gets
acquitted he's not guilty in a court of
law
but he's guilty in what a civil court so
it's like I you're not going to jail but
we're taking everything you own you know
which is crazy to me cuz now you got a
murderer walking around pissed off that
he just took his bed
either put him in jail and take all his
[ __ ] I'll let him go back to his house
but [ __ ] if you gotta if you think the
guy murdered somebody don't take all his
[ __ ] now he's going to the [ __ ] store
he's mad again
so it happened the first time he got mad
[ __ ] all right stamps calm everybody the
US Postal Service is an important tool
for any business stamps.com is the
easiest way to access all the amazing
services of the post office
stamps.com never closes print postage
for any letter or any package at your
convenience 24/7 print postage for any
mail class right now from your own
computer by imprint official US postage
for any letter any package any class of
mail using your own computer and printer
they'll send you a digital scale that
automatically calculates the exact
postage stamps com will even help you
decide the best class of mail based on
your needs no need to lease an expensive
postage meter and there are no long term
commitments I use stamps calm because
you know I'm sending out all my posters
my autographed posters which will be
available in all my shows I'm a [ __ ] if
I can figure out how to use the stupid
scale and all of that crap so can you
absolutely no negative references to the
post office ok
I'll tell you those people down the post
offices they're the salt of the earth
and right now you two can enjoy the
stamps.com service with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale go to stamps
com click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in bur that
stamps comm enter bur alrighty alrighty
alright let's get into the reads here
for this week remembering passwords
alright this is something I have a
problem with you know something I
actually had one of the few patient
moments in my life and I tried it
because I don't know my iCloud password
so I finally just after a year of just
keep Xing that window 90 times every
time I turn on my [ __ ] computer I
finally went on the internet and just
googled how to how to reset it which I
did and I was so excited because the
window finally went away and then I shut
off my computer and then you know we
turn it back on and wants you to read
put in the the [ __ ] password which I
did and now it's not accepting it I'm
right back to square one I remember when
the first time I typed it in it didn't
work and I did it again and it didn't
work you know and as I was hitting send
or whatever or login the third time I
literally said my brain bill don't snap
just relax you'll figure it out and then
it didn't go when I went out every time
every [ __ ] time anyways you know it's
wait actually helping my temper is
watching everybody losing theirs on the
Internet I'm just sitting there going
wow that's what I sound like Jesus
Christ
my wife's living with this I think I'm
gonna buy her some shoes some matching
earplugs hey Bill I was just listening
to the latest podcast check out - lane
for passwords it's easy to use and you
can sync it across your computer phones
etc it auto populates your username and
passwords hope it helps that is
definitely somebody young who write
wrote wrote that in dude why would I the
purpose of the password is that nobody
else knows it that's like one note that
the one thing LifeLock life luck is the
funniest [ __ ] thing in the world to
me yeah give us all your personal
[ __ ] information now not only do I
have to trust you okay you at this
company have now created a Fort Knox of
oh I guess Fort Knox never gets broken
into you've created a basically a giant
[ __ ] sack of cash in the walls that
everybody's now gonna try to get to why
[ __ ] waste my time trying to [ __ ]
hack I'm gonna count here a hack an
account here what I can just hack a life
lock and get everybody's [ __ ] [ __ ] I
appreciate you trying to help me out but
I'm gonna just continue on you know I
don't know if they're gonna hack in
they're gonna hack in but I could just
never [ __ ] remember my [ __ ]
passwords and I don't want to like have
somebody else do it for me my brains
already turned into mush enough as it is
so
but you know people if you want to check
out - lane das h la NE for passwords you
are more than welcome you can get out
there and try that out for yourself
alright number two hi I heard you were
struggling with managing passwords this
is another one I've been using a
password manager called - is this like a
read - lain for a while it's really
great and creates really good passwords
for you for each website and
automatically logs you in there it has a
plugin for various browsers and also an
app for Mac OS love it take care
yeah there's certain things I just don't
outsource that would be one of them
here's something I have to check though
stem cell therapy for hair loss because
I got to tell you something I got
buddies who have done this for their
knees and their [ __ ] shoulders
alright and you know our hands or
something like that and they say they
feel like a kid again
now if there is literally if this gets
to the [ __ ] point
if this [ __ ] [ __ ] works I might go
over to Eastern Europe I swear to God
and I'm gonna come back with a full head
of hair
how [ __ ] weird would that be that
would just be [ __ ] bizarre dude look
at this [ __ ] this is why I shaved my
head look at this look at the [ __ ] show
I love so many of these things that
they're showing as like solutions to
people still look terrible
alright let me see here okay stem cell
therapy for hair cell for hair loss hang
on a second
reviews let's see here let's see what
they say now you know the people that do
it they just flooding it right now this
is like trying to find out like what's
actually healthy they're trying to learn
about
about you Oh hymns they were a they
[ __ ] see they come up stem-cell hair
loss injections do they work I would
almost do this just for the goof you
know how funny would be if I just came
back with a lion's mane of [ __ ] red
hair you know each of us deserves a
truly personal this is a [ __ ] this is
stupid like this is the thing you cannot
get past like how far how many pages do
I have to go where I can actually where
I can actually [ __ ] just find an
actual honest review all right Oh
W Magazine cake thanks to stem-cell
therapy
thinning hair may be a thing of the past
you know like back in the day when you
got like a [ __ ] boil on your face you
just had to have it for the rest of your
life then you started yeah the walking
stick and you got [ __ ] osteoporosis
and you had to go live under a bridge
now not all of that shit's gone right
and now I think that hair loss might go
the same way all right call me creature
our habit or just plain boring but I've
been wearing my hair long by who gives a
[ __ ] what is this yeah these are all
just businesses can I ask you young
people a question how do you find the
answers on the Internet
I don't want a answer I want I want the
answer a hairy question stem cell to
cure baldness and 2017 all right this is
what I'm gonna do because I think
there's a lot of people doing this right
now I'm gonna wait to somebody just
[ __ ] who looks like me to just walk
in one day you know looking like a
[ __ ] all of a sudden just looking
like a rock star and when that [ __ ]
goes down I gotta be like how do you lay
off
I never liked all that other's [ __ ] cuz
they're like yanking [ __ ] from the back
and stick it on top but then it's just
like you know does it work does it not
work but they just go just you know you
just sit down and they go bing bang bing
bang boom on top of your [ __ ] head
well you just watching I don't know an
episode of [ __ ] SWAT or something
then you just leave you come back you
look like you're in the [ __ ] Bee Gees
I'll wait a minute most of them were
bald right oh yeah they're all both
right
we're all dead one of them has hair
plugs all right they like the Kennedys
of falsetto right there's like a million
of them and they all could just [ __ ]
get up there right all right millennial
water crisis dear Beantown Billy in your
recent Conan interview and this past
Thursday you talked about not
understanding why Millennials freaked
out over the water bottle flipping thing
even with all the great technology we
have yes
why do you guys freak out it's actually
not Millennials it's the the generation
after which I keep [ __ ] forget 18
years old generation name is it what is
an alpha what is it
generation Z you [ __ ]
generations which generation are you I
literally look this up and I already
told you guys the [ __ ] answer I
already forget ya generation alpha no
2013 to 2025 sorry no 1995 okay
generation Z alright generation Z that's
what they are they can't get enough of
that [ __ ] water ball trick yeah why
is that he says or she says I thought I
explained my per sec perspective on it
as a millennial and I think you okay now
you're a millennial right and I think
you'd appreciate the humor in it all
right as long as you're 23 to 30 yet
you're a millennial you you bringing up
the great technology we have is part of
the joke oh it's a joke I'm 26
BAM he nailed it and for my entire life
advertising sporting events technology
everything has been getting increasingly
sold to us as the next big thing or the
best thing ever or a once in a lifetime
experience it's all just the same [ __ ]
rehashed over and over with brighter
colors and bigger letters this year's
iPhone is barely better than the last
but [ __ ] it they'll charge a grand more
and people will believe it's better I
like
this person [ __ ] critical thinking
it's a [ __ ] lost art here as I'm
dropping f-bombs all over the place so
freaking out over a water bottle being
flipped is funny it's the most simple
thing
there's no fanfare no tickets being sold
nothing to advertise it's just some
someone flipping a water bottle so let's
freak the [ __ ] out if it lands upright
that'll be funny that's how I see it at
least that was really informing thank
you love the podcast
thanks for the hours of freedom of tape
payment they mean a lot to me go [ __ ]
yourself all right thank you well there
we go
I finally got it answer on the Internet
okay helicopters scene or I got the
answer I like to think helicopter scene
from the Terminator - hey old Billy
fifty-year-old
I'm a big fan of the podcast f is for
family and I especially like that you're
a fan of MotoGP if I can't get enough of
it even though I missed the last couple
of [ __ ] races because there's a long
story we had issues with their TVs also
thanks for introducing me to tales from
the tour bus with Mike judge oh my god
you got to watch that show it's [ __ ]
incredible I'm not really looking for
any advice this time just saw this short
video with directors commentary link
below about the skilled helicopter pilot
in Terminator 2 and thought you might
like it anyways thanks and have a great
weekend yeah I'll definitely post a link
for that it's that scene in Terminator 2
where the skinny guy the next level
Terminator guy he's in a building and
then there's like a helicopter hovering
next to and he basically turns to like
sort of this sort of like a plasma TV
sort of type of liquid and he just sort
of pushes his face into the [ __ ]
helicopter and then he's sitting next to
the guy and he tells the guy to jump out
and then he starts chasing them down the
street and I think it was was a James
Cameron who did that movie he was
talking about being in the helicopter
and how they went from like a thousand
feet down to four feet off the [ __ ]
ground
in like two seconds and having that
feeling of weightlessness I was
literally like
stunt flying in helicopters scares the
[ __ ] I got my palms get sweaty when I
watch it I don't know why because with
like I just something about the main
rotor I just feel like you're gonna hit
something with that and you and then
you're gonna be [ __ ] but if someone
does it in a plane it doesn't freak me
out as much just like the plane seems
like it's more designed to do that you
know even though if you clip something
with your wing you [ __ ] but there's
just something about it
hey is a question for you guys in
aviation right I'm just a [ __ ]
weekend warrior right who got zero hours
this past month I got so busy I was
watching that Tom Cruise movie that was
a great movie where he played this this
drug smuggler it's a long story but they
were three of them were flying in planes
and the DEA was chasing the DEA had like
a [ __ ] jet and they just had like
twin engines so they were able to fly
much slower and so the DEA kept catching
up and then would pass them and then
loop around catch up to him and then
pass them because it you know he
couldn't fly slower he'd fall out of the
[ __ ] sky so eventually the DEA runs
out of gas it was gonna run out of fuel
so they have to turn and go back so they
just basically waited him out so the
joke is then the three planes are
supposed to peel off to the right to go
to the drop where they're gonna drop the
drugs two of them peel off the other one
doesn't and they figure it out cuz the
guy fell asleep he had it on autopilot I
guess so Tom Cruise is trying to [ __ ]
wake the guy up all right
he can't wake him up so he comes up with
his plane and he just ever so slightly
just hits his his wing the guys sleeping
wing with his wing right there's no
[ __ ] way you could do that correct
you know I know I've seen these guys
refuel and you know you kind of bump
into that thing but it's made out of
like rubber right I know I'm sounded
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] but I was looking
at that going that's not possible
wait is it possible is that a true story
that the drug smuggler told I mean I've
seen guys in [ __ ] helicopters not
check their surrounding areas make it
turn
and the main rotor blade [ __ ] does a
nice trim job as some trees and this one
always blows my mind these [ __ ]
[ __ ] don't immediately set it down
and checked if they did any damage to
the blade they just [ __ ] pull power
and they take off like they're the
[ __ ] like they're a landscaper with
the most goddamn overhead ever I was
just like why didn't he just yell into
the [ __ ] headphones I him he did but
I don't know anyway so it's just a
question I have I know I halfway through
that I just in my head was like there's
no [ __ ] way you can do that though
why would you risk that you know gal at
work had dream about me oh here we go
Jesus Christ we got a red shoe diary
here now listen if you have a dream
about a woman at work don't [ __ ] tell
her you did I don't I don't think he
could do that anymore well I have
[ __ ] dream about you I was laying
there Roy you came in and you had your
girls out Roy alright hey Billy dozer
billdozer I get hey bulldozer okay I
have a story you may find humorous slash
scary
it concerns Olay I work with so I've
been talking to this chick for a few
days and I know she digs me lots of
touching closeness yada yada [ __ ] I
like her but now but I'm now I'm now
concerned this morning she told me she
had a dream about us dating
for five years in addition to this she
claimed I failed to propose to her
during those five years oh yeah dude
this this is an open-and-shut case yeah
[ __ ] god bless this woman for being
honest dude I I yeah
walk away slowly briskly and you can do
anything you want because you're not in
a relationship just kidding anyway she
goes now am I wrong for thinking this
was completely crazy it sounded sort of
made-up which made it ten times worse
exactly I like the girl but with this
statement I kind of feel like she wants
to keep me in a body bag or some [ __ ]
if there's one [ __ ]
that I learned in my adult life it it is
go with your gut go with you got you
know something I [ __ ] like three
weeks ago I was talking to this guy and
who was on the road
he's a tour manager for all the you know
other [ __ ] people right and he told
me one of his clients was at this
particular club and this particular club
I always had a feeling the club owner
was stealing from me was just something
about his vibe you know I just I just
could feel it I just I was like this
person that doesn't like me are they
[ __ ] stealing for me I just was weird
and a couple weeks ago I was talking
this person and that club owner his name
came up he said I he goes I caught that
guy putting another extra row of [ __ ]
chairs in there blah blah blah blah and
I was like I [ __ ] knew it I knew it
and my gut was literally saying and for
the longest time I didn't listen to it
if your gut is saying this person wants
to put you in a body bag or some [ __ ]
yeah that's that's the feeling you're
gonna go into a relationship with
anyways I privately consulted some folks
we work with about her dream probably a
bad idea absolutely a bad idea
absolutely a bad idea if this is a spy
movie like those people are now running
for their lives after you get whacked
because they know they also have the
information anyways and they seem to
think she's simply an awkward girl they
think I should give her a shot this
sounds like you talked to women because
they're inserting because what happens
they insert themselves into the [ __ ]
situation and you know they that's just
how it is not if you ask the [ __ ] guy
you know I don't know what we do we [ __ ]
block is what the [ __ ] we do it's funny
women and courage
go ahead go go dater dater you know we
[ __ ] [ __ ] block it's it's bet anyways
what do you think bill Billy butt plug
am I being too harsh or is she doing her
best Freddy Krueger impression thanks I
go with your gut dude you don't I mean
that's gonna be the wife of your kids
you have to say that to kids one day
what was it like when you first met your
mother well she was a meant met our
mother I was cool but
and I got the vibe that uh she wanted to
keep me in a body bag of some [ __ ] you
guys want to get ice cream you know [ __ ]
that dude [ __ ] that I I would go if he
got plenty of fish in the sea
walk away dated for five years and he
didn't he didn't propose to me she's
already putting pressure on you
I don't know if somebody's putting
pressure on her but she's putting
pressure on herself but like that's her
[ __ ] problem that's not you oppa you
want that you want that in your life
spaceflight I want to fly like an eagle
in outer space there's no [ __ ] air
look at my [ __ ] face
hey bill if you could download your
consciousness into a computer slash
robot in order to travel into space
would you alright what the [ __ ] did I
don't know what that means
download my consciousness into a
computer slash robot in order to travel
into space would you know I mean what
how could I do that could you do that
now
you can do that and they can't cure a
hair loss do that's the biggest [ __ ]
scam ever I mean the point of moving
your consciousness is to live longer and
not have the survival requirements we
normally have like oxygen food oh and
having to take shits you might just need
some electricity which seems easier to
produce than oxygen and food in a
long-ass space ride I don't know my
girlfriend broke up with me like a month
ago and I'm drunk just spitballing here
wait a minute I gotta see if this is
like some [ __ ] they're working on right
now this is how dumb I am it's not
behind the time I am a technology like
I'm actually seeing can you wait can you
download your consciousness into a
[ __ ] with you what do I look up here
what [ __ ] list am I gonna get put on
if I [ __ ] look this up downloading
consciousness mind uploading what enough
okay and as a picture says cyborg whole
brain emulation are WBE mind upload or
brain upload sometimes called mind
copying our mind transfer is the
hypothetical hypothetical futuristic
process of scanning the mental state
including long-term memory and self of a
particular brain substrate and copy it
to a computer do you realize do you
realize that you could at first you okay
let's just say they could do that like
they could do that right now the dumbest
thing to do is to be part of that first
wave and do it don't [ __ ] do it cuz
you don't know what's gonna happen and
then also very quickly they're gonna be
like well are there some things that I
could like maybe just delete some
memories like if you had some chick he
could never get over you could just
delete that out of your brain you know
or if something really [ __ ]
humiliating happen to you that caused
you to become like introverted maybe get
rid of that maybe you could become a
better person or is it the painful
things that make us stronger that make
us who we are when we return we'll be
bringing dr. Joyce brothers in here I
never in stood all those doctors like
dr. Joyce brothers is like every day
she's on the Hollywood Squares it's like
what point were you uh practicing
medicine you know celebrity I don't know
you know that's the last thing I'm gonna
look up here history of celebrity can't
[ __ ] spell the word celebrity
psychologists who's the first one
list of psychologists timelines of
psychology history of psychology that
Shep Tom Cruise on it because he knows
he knows the whole history of psychology
right dude he called it he called that
guy glib and years later you found out
that glib son of a [ __ ] had a [ __ ]
goddamn problem did he the breath of
diversity of psychology can be seen by
looking at some of the plaintiff [ __ ]
just give me the list bf Jean Piaget
Sigmund Freud these people actually be
the most boring looking people I've ever
seen in my life Albert bandura Leon
Festinger I always felt like dr. Phil
look like a corrupt cop doesn't he he's
got a [ __ ] pistol in his shoe that
after he accidentally kills you he
[ __ ] puts it in your hand Eric
Erickson it sounds like a fake name he's
got the white hair like Albert Einstein
the mustache that was like this smart
look back in the day
[Music]
celebrity therapist let's this is my
last my last attempt - what the [ __ ] was
dr. Joyce brothers
television vice show pioneer she was a
pioneer oh she died 85 then I feel like
an [ __ ] why I wasn't really [ __ ]
on her I liked her you know summer
vacation after he did you pay prude he
came home she was on a [ __ ] game all
she was on in the afternoon Joyce
brothers passes away peacefully at her
home in New York City on Monday Joyce
brothers the mother of pop psych I'll
pop psychology that's what I want to
look up pop that's so that kind of just
means you don't have to be good at it
right you just have to be like it's that
like psychologists with personalities so
she was the first one pop psychology
personalities how can I get to what the
[ __ ] I want here history of personality
psychology I use the word personality
Sonoma no there's ten famous
psychologists and their [ __ ]
achievement can somebody [ __ ] help me
out here can somebody teach me how to
use the Internet pick him up
no I don't give up I'm just gonna take a
break for the rest of the day I think
they will play with my kid oh and I'm
going to [ __ ] Boston this week baby I
got Springfield on Thursday I got the TD
Banknorth [ __ ] garden all right
on Friday and then I'm [ __ ] in
Connecticut where I think we're the
[ __ ] Hatford Whalers used to play this
is ridiculous how did this happen how
did somebody who flunked every in height
everything in high school I gotta get
these gigs out of the [ __ ] way before
somebody figures it out thank you to
everybody who bought all these goddamn
tickets I'm gonna eat perfect it [ __ ]
workout and being the best most rested
shape I can to give you [ __ ] money's
worth because this is a really humbling
experience like I said I don't know if
I'll ever get to do it again so I'm
gonna get all of it and I will and I'll
be a I'm gonna post some videos of I'm
gonna be [ __ ] jammin with some friends
of mine that I used to [ __ ] play with
way back in the day when I was living
outside of Boston when we had the
[ __ ] garden playing [ __ ] ACDC when
we were in for the forum it was soaked
you know you get together hey do you
know this song do you know that song the
one that we all [ __ ] came together on
was Van Halen ain't talking about love I
played that the Alex Van Halen parts in
the [ __ ] LA forum I got to tell you
dude it was [ __ ] the sickest [ __ ] I
can't even explain it you just sitting
on the drum chair going this is where
[ __ ] John Bonham looked out this is
nuts this is [ __ ] nuts this is where
I saw John thing like a [ __ ] year ago
crushing it on the drums we've got the
[ __ ] red acrylic liquid said
unbelievable so anyways that's the
podcast I will check in on you on
Thursday go [ __ ] yourselves
go Pat's and I'm calling it right now
take the Broncos with the points
all right now so the decision you need
to make is okay bill just said what he's
gonna do all right this is like craps do
I bet on the past or the don't pass line
all right it's up to you so don't
[ __ ] whine to me if you lose your
money that's what I'm betting I'm
betting the [ __ ] I'm taking the Broncos
with the points I don't even know the
spread I can't even name the Broncos
quarterback I just know they got von
Miller and I like that okay all right
bye